Це допомагає жити. Ось і все.
Треба йти до кінця, боротися до останнього.
Українська збірна на "Іграх нескорених".
Тут кожен учасник має свою унікальну історію.
Та всіх об'єднує одне: власним прикладом вони доводять,
що жодна бойова травма не може зламати силу духу.
Не дивлячись на втрату кінцівки чи травму -
українська команда не втратила жагу до перемоги!
Подивитися на гру українських учасників
в об'єднаній команді з регбі
на візках прийшов і принц Гаррі.
Саме він заснував "Ігри нескорених" у 2014 році.
Втім на коментарі у принца часу не було.
Та на церемонії відкриття змагань
Гаррі у своїй промові виразив повагу
українській збірній.
Я хочу відзначити команду України
і зокрема одну конкретну людину - Тайру.
А от під час матчу українські гравці
появу поважного гостя навіть не помітили.
Я не знав, що принц на нас дивиться,
але я радий, що мені сказали.
Я так розумію, що він вболівав за нас також,
чи прийшов подивитися, як ми граємо з іншими.
Немає такого, що за когось конкретного,
він прийшов подивитися гру.
Сподіваюся, що йому сподобалося.
Але жодні перемоги у жодних Іграх,
каже Павло, не важливі,
поки немає перемоги найбільшої.
Найкраще відчуття перемоги -
це коли ми переможемо у боротьбі
за нашу незалежність, перестануть
гинути наші люди і наші військові.
Тоді буде справжнє відчуття перемоги.
А так це тимчасова радість, задоволення.
Я сподіваюсь, що це допоможе іншим хлопцям,
які з нами грали: адаптуватися,
реалізуватись і відкинути негативні думки
та весь негатив війни хоча б на певний час.
Це допомагає жити.
"Дім для поваги" - девіз "Ігор нескорених" цього року.
Це спортивні змагання для ветеранів
та військовослужбовців, які зазнали травм.
У Німеччині змагання відбуваються вперше.
Українську команду представляють
25 спортсменів-військовослужбовців
у 10 видах спорту.
Регбі на візках, волейбол сидячи
і баскетбол. Далі йдуть
настільний теніс, стрільба з лука,
індивідуальні види: пауерліфтинг,
веслування, легка атлетика, плавання.
Це місце, де всі один одного поважають,
де цінностями є не боротьба за результат,
за медалі, за нагороди,
а за повернення до нормального життя.
Тут немає людей, які не рівні між собою.
Всі в рівних умовах, всі один одного поважають.
Всі один одного підтримують і допомагають один одному.
Всіх цих людей об'єднує спорт
і допомагає їм повернутися до життя
і відчувати себе так, як вони
відчували до отриманих травм.
На початку в німецький Дюссельдорф
на Ігри мало їхати лише 24 учасники.
Та додаткове місце спеціально зарезервували
для парамедикині Юлії Паєвської,
відомої як "Тайра."
Яку на церемонії відкриття згадував принц Гаррі.
Під час минулорічних змагань доброволиця
перебувала у російському полоні
і не змогла взяти участь.
Я мусила бути на Invictus Games.
Минулого року я провела цей час,
коли хлопці змагалися в Гаазі,
в Донецькому СІЗО, "на підвалах".
І це те, що в списку завдань ця "галочка"
не стояла, що зроблено.
А тепер буде зроблено!
Тому що я обіцяла.
Через проблеми з хребтом "Тайра"
тимчасово пересіла у візок,
але своєї участі у змаганнях не скасувала.
Треба йти до кінця, боротися до останнього
скільки є сили. А є надія чи ні -
все одно потрібно виходити.
Як сьогодні я вийшла та знала,
що це не буде топ-результат,
але я була заявлена в списку
і якщо я не з’явлюся на змаганнях, то це наче я злякалася.
А я не боюсь.
Саме адаптація - ключова мета "Ігор нескорених".
Через війну Росії проти України дуже багато жінок
та чоловіків отримують поранення.
І про те, як їм адаптовуватися і реабілітовуватися
в суспільстві - потрібно думати вже зараз.
Ми повинні створювати умови для реабілітації,
а спорт це невід'ємна складова реабілітації як такої.
Тому перебуваючи на змаганнях такого рівня
люди бачать, яка підтримка.
Їх всіх об'єднує одна ціль, одна мета.
І це надихає.
Люди повертаються зовсім іншими людьми.
Багато людей приїжджає з різного роду травмами.
Є видимі і невидимі,
є посттравматичні синдроми,
які візуально ми можемо навіть не бачити.
Але ми навіть не уявляємо, що в людей в голові відбуваються.
Люди можуть бути замкнуті,
люди можуть просто важко переносити
велику кількість людей навколо них.
Їм потрібен час на адаптацію.
Звичайно, що важко адаптуватися.
Але в першу чергу треба прийняти себе,
змиритися з тим і прийняти себе.
І далі буде набагато краще жити,
і суспільство тебе полюбить, і ти полюбиш суспільство.
На цьогорічних Іграх 600 учасників із 22 країн.
Попри дух змагання - всі підтримують один одного.
Це неймовірно. Я абсолютно вражений,
тому що всі ми знаємо, що відбувається в Україні.
Але коли члени збірної України приїжджають сюди
і представляють країну, родини та людей удома,
це дуже емоційно, коли ви думаєте про це.
І треба стримувати сльози, усвідомлюючи все те,
через що вони проходять.
Але вони все одно прийшли сюди із сім’ями,
мають сили посміхатися і підбадьорювати інших.
Підтримку Україні й українській збірній
на церемонії відкриття висловив
і міністр оборони Німеччини Борис Пісторіус.
Ми ніколи не повинні припиняти підтримку України,
незалежно від того, скільки часу це триватиме.
Крім ветеранів в українській команді
багато діючих військових, які потім планують
вертатися на передову.
Як от капітан української збірної Олександр Маковей
або Макоша, як його лагідно називають побратими.
Так капітан збірної виборює для команди золото!
Максимум хочеться зробити для країни,
заявити світу про нас, що в нас йде війна,
в нас гинуть хлопці такі, як я, які позитивні,
які цінують життя, які хочуть жити у вільній Україні.
І саме це донести світу.
Наші партнери, вони нам допомагають,
але цього трошечки мало.
Потрібно більше, потрібні літаки,
ракети далекобійні, потрібно закрити небо.
Тому що дуже важко воювати на передку,
коли в тилу по твоїх будівлях, по твоїх рідних,
близьких прилітають ракети
і ти нічого не можеш з цим зробити.
Саме родина - головне джерело мотивації
для Олександра: як в бою, так і в реабілітації.
Дружина - це в мене взагалі мій особистий янгол
охоронець. Настя моя донька - це мій мотиватор.
Зараз завдяки їй я повернувся в спорт
і почав займатися спортом.
Свою перемогу капітан присвячує родині.
Крім доньки і дружини на змаганнях
за військового зболіває й однорічний синочок.
Це син капітана команди Олександра Маковея.
Теж Олександр Олександрович Маковей.
Як ти за тата вболіваєш розкажи?
Саньок - це взагалі дитина, яку я чекав дев'ять років.
Мені Бог дав сина, спадкоємця,
який буде носити мої медалі.
Поки одні учасники української збірної змагаються -
інші приходять їх підтримувати.
Так Олександр Будько, позивний "Терен",
після власного змагання у жимі лежачи
прийшов вболівати за друзів.
У минулому бариста, а з початком повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії - доброволець Олександр
під час боїв у Харківській області
отримав важке поранення і втратив обидві ноги.
Та це не зупинило військового,
він написав книгу, виступає в театрі,
а тепер і показує спортивні успіхи.
Але для самого Олександра справжнє натхнення ті -
хто на передовій.
Ті, кого героїзує наш народ -
це і є дійсно ті герої, які ведуть боротьбу.
І до цих пір я в якійсь мірі навіть заздрю їм,
тому що, чесно кажучи, замість цього всього
я б поміняв би, не скажу, що на окоп…
але на активні бойові дії, бо хотілося б бути разом з ними.
А для тих, хто зараз в такій ситуації, після поранення,
то хочеться сказати, що нехай подивляться
всі можливості, які можуть очікувати їх
і не варто хнюпитись,
тільки потрібно працювати над собою.
І ось це все, будь ласка, доступне для кожного ветерана,
пораненого військового.
Тому тільки вперед, бо кожен капітан своєї долі.